hello my name is Markiplier welcome to
Garden of banban I am also alive also I
don't know why that guy's there but he's
gonna stick around for a little bit
since Alexian isn't here at the moment
this is our new lexian everybody say hi
hello
good to see you
hi yes welcome uh so I'm not dead
um
cheers to that I suppose
where have I been
well ain't that none of your business in
all of mine but I'll tell you where I've
been I've been exactly nowhere what in
the hell is going on there
what in the hell is happening
they had that
when did they add these um Facebook live
ass uh Instagram live hearts
do I get points for that do I get extra
YouTuber points for that do I go up in
the rankings is that good for me ah yes
I'm back um so I I'm back with the game
you all know and love you all love it
you all know it
[Music]
I don't know
all right here's the thing
is this working is this working are you
is it getting quieter for you
become an NPC God I hope not oh maybe
I've been this whole time
um did it did the game get quieter right
the game got quieter right I got a new
interface and I haven't gotten a new
interface in a long time because the go
XLR is being discontinued or something
like that so I got something different
and I don't know how it works
uh exactly
so I got to make sure that everything's
on the up and up okay so if the game if
the game's still
it's a little is it better is it good
sounds good see that's a thing
see that's the thing I feel like I can
hear it better and I can I can do on the
Fly mixing I feel like I can be a better
YouTuber and I'm starting to realize
that maybe the go XLR wasn't good in the
first place
um
sound great
I love to hear that that's incredible so
what
I forgot that guy was there
um so the mic wait what did you just say
say the mic sounds weird
hang on let me see okay if I mute that
the mic sounds weird
it's actually kind of loud it's a little
loud probably see this is all new
I gotta check out to see Mike sounds
weird why is my mic sound weird
like doesn't sound weird no it doesn't
it's fine are you with me
I come back from an extended vacation
which I you know I was taking a vacation
and definitely not editing iron lung you
know that
it's robotic
no
how how why sounds fine sounds odd
sounds good it kind of does
well there's only one way to answer this
one I just gotta pull up my own stream
and I gotta check for myself and that'll
give me the answer that I need
hold on one second
all right
let's see here
I muted all right
let's see here hello Jack one two talk
talk entertain me hello hello hello
hello hello to talk talk entertain me it
does hello it is hello something's wrong
talk entertain me something's going on
something's wrong it is no behind it you
can't listen to obviously there's an
echo going on right now but there's
something else something's wrong it does
sound a little off no behind it you
can't listen to obviously there's a neck
no it doesn't it sounds something's
going different about it it does sound a
little off no behind it but why does it
sound a little off that's a question
that I need to ask myself something's
going different about it
but it does sound off there's something
that's going different something is
different about it because I haven't
been able to do a test recording to see
I don't know why it's what it is but it
does so I gotta know exactly something
is different about it because I haven't
been able to do a test recording
there's no bass in the voice I don't
know
I got I got enough bass let me see
there's there's sometimes there's like
some
there's like some is this any whoa what
did that do is that different how does
that sound I need to turn on my stream
again hold on what did that do what did
that do is that different is that
different on my stream again hold on
something's different what did that do
is that different is that different
again what is different what is
different something's different it's
like there's for this one where there
wasn't before there wasn't oh that's
yeah it's like there's no that's this
one where there wasn't before okay oh
boy okay so in this one there's hold on
that's not what I need
there's effects right it's different
it's different hold on
there's differences
de-esser I don't need that high pest
filters off de-esser Noise Gate
compressor there's a compressor on there
but I I don't know if that would be
doing that much wouldn't be making it
sound hollow like that that's for sure
I the big bottom effect I gotta turn up
the big bottom is that better is that a
bigger bottom is my bottom bigger is it
maybe if I tune my big bottom how about
this for a tuned big bottom is that a
better big bottom or do I need to do I
need to I need to amp up the big bottom
so it extends to a farther range of the
low frequencies is this better is this
sounding a little better on the big
bottom how's that big bottom much better
big bottom I'll turn on my stream much
better big bottom no that doesn't sound
right much better big bottom no no
something's going on something
something's happening and I don't know
what
it's something to do with the routing
and I don't know why the the routing
would be anything but smart
but it's not
you
how's that
did that fix it
is that a little better
is that a little better hello everybody
my name is Markiplier
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
hello everybody my name is there was
there was an echo there was another
Channel see that's the stupid thing
about the routing on this is like you
can get every routing into every little
piece of it but because I have chat also
set up like chat is in if someone was on
a Discord call with me they could be
their voice could be in here yeah that's
better all right we're back in it baby I
need to turn down my big bottom my
bottom got a little big there and I need
to I need everyone to understand that
that's not my true bottom
um
I'll I encourage everyone to reach out
reach deep within themselves and access
their true bottom
um but in all honesty I I gotta be I got
to be level with you guys that ain't my
true bottom I got I gotta tune down my
big bottom it's it's not that big is
what I'm trying to say
it's like uh my bottom ain't that big
um
the Powerpuff
this is a very mythical power bottom um
so there's also the Exciter and I I the
all right the oral Exciter is um the
other half of it so you got your big
bottom and your oral Exciter right so
you've got legit these are legitimate
terms I don't know why you would think
anything other than that but you you
gotta tune in your oral Exciter and your
big bottom
so
it's uh it's not oral oral a-u-r-a
-l oral so you got your oral Exciter and
your big big bottom also yes I'm in the
middle of a hurricane apparently but
while I'm in the middle of a hurricane
I'm gonna ride this bad boy out which um
now is this still coming in okay is this
so is this still good it's my big bottom
big enough my oral exciting exciting
enough
seems like it might be a little loud let
me let me turn the spiciness down a
little bit
right about there
right about there right about there
right over there right up there
right about there right about there okay
right about there game too loud right
about there
right about there no yes no yeah right
right about there
right okay good all right we're doing
this new game whoa I am so ready for
garden of ban ban uh I didn't even
mention it but on the main menu it said
you know they always have a pre oh
all right right this this horribly
depressing thing for a parent looking
for their missing child time is a
delicate matter click the clock to
advance time click clock to waste time
so you just run all about out of time
um so where have I been obviously I've
been editing a movie and also if you
heard on distractible if you've been
listening to that which you have if you
haven't
what's up with you
what's up with you there was this Whole
sag thing I talked about it on a on the
uh this on the other stream that I was
doing here
um but uh good news is
I'll tell you the good news later What's
Happening Here
why are we
well that's concerning
you know I didn't know what I was
expecting to come out of this but it
wasn't that
just dust on my monitor or their two
eyes looking at me right now you see you
seeing what I'm seeing are you seeing
this you've seen you've seen these
there's like two you see in that you
seeing that
seeing that let me no sorry let me
enhance it for you uh if I put a filter
on this let's put a color correction on
there yeah let's turn that gamma up
no no that's not eyes I thought that was
eyes ah this is dumb and stupid I
thought there were eyes looking at me
this is dumb
here
all right what do we have
what changed
I don't know what changed
I don't know
well I sure didn't find my missing kid
but oh well
Hey look it's my missing kid
whoa the mouse sensitivity is a little
high yeah shift to Sprint I know can I
can I change this hi what you doing
hi okay
though
my goodness
my word
goodness gracious I can't hit Escape
everybody I want you to know that I
can't leave this game I think we're
locked in here until the end of time uh
there we go
it's a little better
where am I
grab
I don't know if I wanna
know if I wanna
if lexian was here he would add in some
jump scare sounds elixian
added jump scare
thanks licks soon thank you
uh oh i really grabbed him
right I forgot about the lore of the
last episode uh this thing's parents
exploded or something I can't remember
quite what happened I think they well
all right then okay
hi whoa all right man this camera Shake
is making me nauseous but all right
I hope I don't have to go down any paths
that are a mystery I also I wish I could
see what was happening are you still
there
still there
oh what is that oh
all right well that's um
at least it's a turtle so I guess I
don't have to run away oh man I wish I
could see Danny thing go go go go go
hey a door oh oh oh my God ah oh I see e
oh wait yes this
oh
oh I know you
uh uh you okay
uh okay there we go let me turn my
oh I can't all right no no changing that
all right well you're right
he's just scared he's just scared guys
he's just scared
um yeah I remember These Guys these were
the dudes who um oh man that's
unfortunate for you could you still kill
me if I get close to you oh do I want to
find out yeah I do
oh
what was even the point
yeah try to eat me
all right well this is weird oh this is
awkward whoa my God
why did you get up
hmm interesting
fascinating all right whatever so I got
this bird uh I guess that's
good
I don't know what that's about
left Mouse button to use my toy here on
a live stream
come on guys
and it's not that kind of stream
um all right gotta teleport it okay go
blonk
go block go go Blanc go ahead you go
there stay
[Music]
forgot what
ah so you probably you probably won't be
able to jump down if you go up here will
you
uh all right well this is a fortunate
stay
[Music]
there we go see I'm real good at Bam Bam
I'm real good at Bang Bang
what happens if I leave my kid
a kid
what are you trying to do
hey what's up
that's a stupid God he's lucky that he
looks like that creature I made from
Spore so long ago all right you well
nope all right come nope nope I you know
really all right
goodbye
hey wait a minute
uh uh nope really
goodbye I guess
later
that's sad
oh well
what was that
I'm
what is happening
quite an opening to the game you know
God admit quite an opening to the game
I hit the Forbidden Vape that's what I
did I just couldn't handle it it was
just too powerful that's why you don't
just you don't you know blast fat hogs
out of every random Vape you come across
gotta be careful gotta be smart
listen up
that whole act if you
if you you're a prisoner now
now you'll do what you're told without
any questions
understood who says to use who's
understanding
I will ask you yes or no questions and
you'll answer them using the buttons on
your left and right I ain't one for
pressing buttons forward yes
I know and forward a bit of a uh uh a
misnomer it's a matter of perspective
uh what
I don't know what you've even asked me
because I wasn't listening also what's
wrong with you you got a wide stance I
respect that uh yes I did it whatever it
was I did it you saved a lot of time for
someone that needs every minute on their
hand so thank you for that hey use
welcome that someone shall not be
mentioned who's
well have you ever come in contact with
the threats shown on the board yeah yep
yes I has really
I'm surprised you're still in one piece
hmm third I'm very tough maybe in
contact with the threats shown on the
board oh yeah yeah I seen that heads up
four questions uh-huh have you ever come
in contact with a threat shown on the
board
now I'm real good with faces I think
that I would have uh
think that I would have known that wait
wait all right is the uh volume up
because I hear it fine why do I hear it
it's too quiet
let me know when you hear a low ominous
Rumble
how about this
is this good do you hear a low ominous
Rumble
how about now
low ominous Rumble
how am I the one getting older if your
old ass years can't hear the game I hear
it fine why don't you turn up your
hearing aids out there why don't you
crank up your hearing aids a little bit
I hear everything perfectly I got 20 20
auro Vision over here you wish you could
hear as good as me anyway I I it's a new
it's a new mixer all right it's a new
mixer I'm trying to figure it out I got
it I got it my phone is at max volume
well get a better phone I do seem to be
peeking a bit when I talk but that
doesn't make any sense why would that
happen why am I not showing up on the
end oh this I don't know what this is
and I don't know how this is fine you
hear it perfectly well there's nothing
playing right now so it's your own fault
oh anyway
no I thought so um you must have come
from the floors above
fifth question have you ever come in
contact with a threat shown on the board
well it depends uh I don't know if this
is the male version or the female
version I see a little bit of a thing at
the top but I guess I've seen both so
yeah that one gives me the creeps hmm
six questions have you ever come in
contact with a threat shown on the board
I have hey handsome how you been I could
tell something about your answers were
fishy huh what's up all right grab your
belongings from the back and step out of
the room but you're right there I can
you're not that hidden sir I can I can
tell watch I'm gonna show everyone else
how dumb you is one second
you're you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna be you're gonna be upset you're
gonna be you're gonna be mad when I
prove yous wrong
you thought you could pull a fast one on
me ah look who it is
thought so
thought so got you you wish you were
hitting wish you were unfortunately I'm
very very smart I'm incredibly smart
look who I came in contact with look who
I supposedly have never seen before in
my eyes swole that's the first thing
that you guys
swole let's get some let's see some
contrast in here maybe a little more
saturation yeah that'll be that'll do it
let's shift the Hues a bit all right we
took some psychedelics let's just uh
let's just roll for a little bit here
there's opacity that just makes it
darker contrast more gamma more
brightness down weirdly enough
yeah it's looking pretty good
you guys like this okay it's a new it's
it's a new eyes that we all have so if
you guys haven't adjusted your eyes this
looks perfectly normal uh if you don't
think that this looks normal there's
something wrong with your eyes so you
need to get a doctor to look at that
because this is perfectly normal so just
so you know anyway
Bonk all right so that's that's this is
abnormal if you couldn't see that before
you uh you don't have a very good night
vision
it's completely normal where am I going
my belongings
you don't even work here
on Earth are you doing this deep down
anyway partner
you could follow whoa we can talk more
inside
well damn
all right partner
carefully it's not very sturdy you
realize I'm not there right you do
realize that I'm not I'm not there
I'm not I'm not there
my boy
my bro I'm not I'm not there I'm taking
in the environment
uh all right
Welcome To The Kingdom uh-huh
[Music]
wow wow it's not up to me to decide what
to do with your partner
we need to talk to the queen
and when we do
show respect oh
thank you
what
what is this oh
[Music]
am I supposed to be like right behind
you or what's
what do you what do you I didn't agree
to follow you ah man I can't all right
[Music]
Hey look it's my thing yeah whatever I
guess hi I'll be right there don't worry
I should have been on the way before but
I wasn't so um
getting getting over here all right I'm
on the way
hold on
[Music]
I'm coming
you like a goat is this a bunny
you a kangaroo
I just got man I'm not impressed I've
seen bigger so your majesty
I'm finished interrogating the new
captive huh and how would you relate the
fruitfulness of that interrogation on a
scale of one to ten huh
zero they don't talk much and I think
they came from a surface uh the surface
there's a new one
did they say what they're doing down
here I'm afraid not
a worried parent can spot another
worried parent from a mile away
huh I've heard the screens in the crash
from above
you're here in search of your child you
could tell that from my screams
most humans have ceased to come down to
this floor for quite some time now
we could help with getting you back up
to the upper floors but
allow us to introduce ourselves first
uh-huh I'm listening
continue talking
I am so hearing you this is
the protector and only other citizen of
the Kingdom uh-huh
oh yeah
[Music]
three to be exact three
hi are you looking at me
I was previously too occupied to go
collect them uh-huh the coming hours
but this is not your backpack a sheriff
a company
your majesty you should be focused on
protecting you uh
you win are you still looking over there
I'm not over there
ma'am oh my God
good
oh God
all right let's head to the station can
I have this and take this and I have
this all right anyway
your majesty my Majesty uh
talk lessons see where that goes are you
talking
does he think I'm there oh God
oh oh God he's having a huge huge huge
Exposition speech
[Music]
what's in your pouches skates and we all
die
what did I miss
what were you what did I miss what about
we all die what about laughing and all
die
what was that why do you keep walking
[Music]
all right um are you done talking now
that I'm here are you are you done are
you gonna reiterate what you said about
everyone dying because I feel like um I
feel like I I was definitely walking
behind you and listening um I feel as
though if you ever turned around or
looked over your shoulder I don't know
if you have the neck to be able to do
that looks a little thick looks a little
girthy
um yeah
scattered across three stations
you get to using the using the transport
system
they look like elevators
for me two for you and two for little B
here
should be some scattered around
uh
all right
I guess hey can I get oh wait a minute
oh
Bill oh oh sorry go over there a billion
okay this is a nightmare it has to be
I thought I was ready to witness the
things down here but I was severely
mistaken they said the training would be
enough I felt betrayed and I have felt
scared but never both at the same time
I should have never put my life in my
co-workers hands
I've been left behind as they ran away
like the cowards they are and now I'm
left to talk to a piece of paper what
was that screaming coming from above and
what on Earth would that thing that
approached us it was almost like nothing
as a floating face
the training manual said nothing
definitely nothing about the giggles
that seem to be getting closer and
closer to me
all right anyway uh a billion oh wow so
do I just shoot you in the face and
collect the billion or do I do something
else all right
a billion
I have no tickets ah you need tickets of
course of course of course
of course of course that's what I'm
doing here
good hi that's what I'm doing
don't know why ah of course of course of
course of course
of course
am I Australian
100 sure
um
is that four or five that I got
a billion a a billion
a billion that's so many
uh-huh
okay was that enough was that five or
six was that five or six I don't
remember
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
there it is all right good we got it
uh he missed it lamal really what's
wrong with you god what happened to just
supporting the streamer okay what
happened why are you razzing me why
where did he go
all aboard
I didn't know you could talk hi I'll be
right behind you don't worry Sheriff God
you're scary
no oh
ah
what was even the point of you getting
on this
a conductor are you supposed to be isn't
this supposed to be your job to conduct
and mine is it not what about what
hi what huh
[Music]
what
oh that's how it works
I'll get your confusion partner I really
do you do oh okay massive Bob petal toad
with a hat protecting the giant purple
kangaroo Queen for
after I was thrown down here by your con
like I was trash
I was hopeless aimless cold
and in miles away from a promised
surface
long story short I was found and
accepted at my lowest
it was then that I declared myself the
ultimate protector of the queen uh-huh
it's a Cause worth fighting for no
good-hearted individuals deserve
protection
uh-huh
is that me
also isn't this supposed to be uh like a
kindergarten
um I feel like I I'm not 100 sure
oh we're here partner
let's get this over with oh oh all right
remind me again what we're doing and and
how close we are going to be to our own
demise hey what's up Bard you don't walk
so hard when you should be in the
administration room within the
ventilation corridors yeah but it looks
like the door's locked
is that where your way of saying that I
need to do the thing to make it fun
God I wish I could go through all my
problems in life like that I just any
obstacle I see the nearest person of my
God if only there was a way for me to
get a thousand dollars right now
if only
if only there was God don't look at me
like that what that
uh
so
go get him buddy
okay uh
have they made that thing faster
[Music]
wow that's never mind
hello hi what is that oh it's a light oh
that's no problem
or reflection
oh why what's happening what do you mean
you stay in there and don't move I'll
figure out a way to get the door open
what what
you mean you could do that this whole
time
hi I'm a hungry snake
uh
uh no oh
hello
well this is uncomfortable
um
oh you don't look so bad
oh you look sweet unless this is your
penis
please don't be your
I guess I should run
um yeah
I thought there was nothing happening
there was a whole lot of something hey
help oh
these toad Stars never disappoint
partner
that my friend was the jester I was
talking about what did you AKA bitter
giggle
he now knows we're not at the Kingdom
let's grab the party get out of here
uh-huh all right so the question on my
mind is
what is what do you mean by get toadstad
and also was that his penis cause he
definitely was not a snake
um
all right whatever
what is this supposed to be
what is this
I mean actually now that I think about
it this might be the most functional I
know my enemies
were being stopped
these fans are interconnected they make
perfect traps
I'm sure there's a way we can tell which
ones are rigged we just need to figure
it out
what
oh here we go ah can sense Danger
and we'll
sing when there's danger I don't know if
that's the best response to Danger bird
huh
Danger
what if I just run blindly through
everything
I'm running for it
Jay
[Music]
so
look I had to find out what I didn't
know how I would be warned that
something was going to happen
it just happened
that's it that's all there is to it
let me turn up the volume so that you
guys can get spooked even more when that
happens again because I was a little I
was a little worried about where the
volume was at when I'm when I'm talking
but um seems to everything be okay
unless I'm peeking the microphone at all
which I don't know and I don't care shut
up
all right
give me the goods
hello
sniff
all right let's try over here
Smith
no
oh maybe not all right
duly noted
if
all right easy
careful now
all right oh
all right well this seems tedious
oh come on
why don't you go first I don't even
think that thing could kill you
what would even be the point of me going
first with a bird why don't you just go
if you can sense being stalked
you're just making me do work
I hate doing work
God damn you
stop being so goddamn creepy with your
yellow eyes get your liver checked
[Music]
get out of my way
it's freaking sticky
how many friends do you have that are
sticky
uh
almost there guys don't worry almost
there
one of these days I'll get two in a row
not today
yes
oh come on
oh
oh double peep
very scary
all right double peep wow
okay
I'm not gonna run blindly into this in
case
it's some kind of trick at the end there
we go all right we did it yay
[Music]
game
how dare you be smart to the name of
cartoon of Van ban
greatest gamed
to ever grace your YouTubes
you think they just
you think this isn't actually you know
honestly I don't get why everyone is so
up in arms about it however I will say
the price did go up for this last
chapter quite a bit
um which is still everyone developers
set your place your price know your
worth that's fair that's totally fair
but also
getting crazy anyway
uh
uh system operable
name the little bird he's probably gonna
die
you think that look look yeah look God
what a this would be a great thumbnail
oh you guys are weird this this little
thing this thing's gonna die
I I don't know how this game ends I
don't know how this is gonna go
I'm not gonna name this thing because
he's gonna die this little thing
dead over under on this thing being dead
by the end of this what do you bet I'm
willing to bet that this thing is gonna
die all right okay let's just be honest
with ourselves this I'm not gonna name
him
well I guess I got a name if I'm gonna
put a name on the tombstone all right
listen you guys you guys figure
something else out for the name and I'll
I'll I'll listen I'll I'll make a real
nice gravestone I'll make a real nice
one it'll be like full marble it's not
gonna be anything like artificials can
be real marble
it's gonna be great
it's gonna be great all right you you
get it you get that you work that out
amongst yourselves and uh that'll be a
temporary shutdown why would I want to
do that
this is what I want to do
this is what I do that seems purple but
it's
not the right purple
all right Kentucky
I'm assuming that's in reference to
Kentucky Fried Chicken which is you know
the the memorial dinner is going to be
it's gonna be delicious let me tell you
that wow
we went all this way for one COG
that's the part we need from this
section
let's head back and see if it'll fit oh
are you just gonna you just gonna plow
through this wait hold on
no
you better I better be able to follow
you here
God it's just the confidence with with
she walks that's all it is
Colonel Sanders that's pretty good Tiny
Bird Tim uh that's a that's a classic
that's not bad
um you know chicken dumplings
no no Little Bo Peep no no no no not at
all this is this is ridiculous I can't
believe it I can't believe
pet name Steve yeah right what an old
meme
for a while
baby bird Bobby
hey wait a minute
why'd the score go up for the feline
also why is there a door over there that
has not been opened
isn't that a little peculiar
hmm
okay
never been checked for spina bifida
I guess we go now
where do we go
oh never mind what was wait then what
was
yeah
frick
that was some speed you didn't you
didn't feel any G's on that one that was
that was intense
um
all right anyway
Hubert
hi uh bye where are we going
little LSD I don't think so
why did we go here
I didn't Define this place
oh never mind we're not going here
where are we going
I have no idea
Cheetos
nah
swample nah nah
Burt Reynolds no
man I'm not good at naming things I'm
not good if you guys can agree on a name
that would I would do that for the
elevator to see if the park fits all
right you got it buddy if you guys can
come up with a name chicken twisties I
can't have chicken in the name that's
that's just lazy
pickle no Bob no bin bin
[Music]
no yes no I don't know I'm terrible at
name I never name anything I don't name
anything never ever never there's no
history or evidence of me ever naming
anything
[Music]
purple bird
ah that makes sense uh
where are you going all right the
elevator
right the elevator
Bartholomew Mack literally like ins when
when I made space I literally named
characters
uh there was celsi F calvina
that is the level of naming that I do
literally it is no more profound or
interesting than that that is as good as
it gets with me I can't do anything
about names there's Gunner B Gunnerson
the middle name the b stands for bullet
that and it's like I can't I don't do
anything anyway to say that the new
approach to encapsulate in case 9 with
his desired identity is backfired would
be an understatement perhaps the amount
of time of case 9 schedule that was
dedicated to watching Western media was
too excessive while case 9 has fully
embraced himself as ban bans gang's
protector he has grown to believe that
everyone that is not part of Batman's
gang is a criminal including inanimate
objects with human features the
facilities staff and most likely
children it did not help that last week
was completely dedicated to how to
properly catch in prison and interrogate
criminals his size or larger no staff
member is safe near case nine as his
methods are simply too violent for a
human being to survive
case 9 has become a real Western Sheriff
where existing as one will ruin
everything
's not ready for
UFO buffo and guyvanium
what
whatever
okie dokie
oh
perfect that's one of three where what
I'll stay here and put everything
together
for now maybe just hang around the place
and talk to the queen ready
what
this doesn't make what
wait
what
I don't understand I don't understand
also I need to I'm gonna check something
real quick
just need to see Hello everybody no no
no not that good I'm gonna check
something
I just need to see damn it I was too
slow because I clicked on the wrong
thing just checking something you need
to see damn it I was too slow because I
clicked on the wrong thing just checking
something
all right cool good did it done it did
done done okay let's go
let's talk to this queen or something
bottom bird no get out what are you
weird stop
anyway you have so name it death uh
it looks so sad oh it knows it knows it
knows it's gonna die
oh nose goes no nose is gonna goes nose
goes nose goes to heaven his name is
nose because we knows he's gonna die
that's nose over there and when he dies
I'm gonna go oh nose you go nose when
nose dies no not nose
well not like nose nose but nose goes
well I did do nose goes but anyway nose
is gonna die nose goes and nose gone
when nose goes you know what I mean
anyway that's nose
I I don't know it's the beak of the nose
something like that anyway that's nose
we love nose nose goes
well no nose goes is not the name nose
is the name nose goes those
so
I hope your journey was worth it
a little more useful it's not usable at
all
I wanted to let you know how much I
respect the things you are doing to get
your child back I got a cog
putting your life on the line and
fighting forces far more powerful than
you like
that admirable thank you it's a token of
my respect please accept this blue key
heart while not much it is what we
consider a symbol of trust well thank
you thank you very much that you are
officially a citizen number
thank you
thank you is there any way to get that
he was in a damaged stage
he asked for you so perhaps you could
stop
it's
called I was thinking that I was like
man I can't get the audio balance right
it's not me the music is just better
ah that that makes so much sense I mean
wow look at the languages God damn
International over here wow
wow I didn't I thought there were no
audio settings because it just says
apply here I didn't see this oh here I
was being like God I can't get this
audio right no matter what when in
reality it wasn't my fault at all
but I do want some music because when it
gets all spooky and loud I don't know
whatever all right thank you for the
blue key card thank you what is this
ah macropus Rufus uh-huh as per
Management's request in pursuit of
documenting the case of reaction case 14
has been informed that it will be moved
to the lower levels and that the lltt
have been contacted
the same common reasonable demeanor that
case 14 is since the modified GB
solution was applied to her system she
processed she proceeded to ask about
whether a similar size tooling will be
provided for where she was being moved
to which an affirmative answer was given
afterwards she proceeded I can't even
read this it's all wibbly wobbly after
where she proceeded to ask if the new
place is where she would put her pouch
to use and finally get to teach good
children the importance of staying good
and what happens to bad children towards
the person's staff member said they were
uncertain the answer will now forever
remain no case 14 was also informed that
receptor will be taken away to be
further researched and then returned as
the case's firm belief that the scepter
has magical
foreign
[Music]
in all this world where there's like oh
yeah there's science going on in this
kindergarten
you guys take
Magic
all right whatever get me out of this oh
man I'm not where am I hello ah there we
go thank you oh glorious and probably
magical ruler with lots of sewage behind
you
go well
anyway
[Music]
she's magical yeah magical all these
very magical look at the mushrooms very
magical look at the cloud it's very
magical did you know a hurricane is
coming
did you know that that's true that's 100
true there's a hurricane coming
uh I don't think there's been a
hurricane coming for where I am in uh
what like 100 years or something like
that
so that's kind of interesting
what am I looking at
oh oh oh
the cake gone
cake gone
cake is gone
the cake gone
interesting so what do I do about the
any of this
what do I do about this
what do I do but yeah no there's a
there's a hurricane coming by the time
it gets to where I am it's probably
going to be more like um like a tropical
tropical storm or tropical depression or
whatever they call I don't know the
distinction
um but yeah so
yeah
Norbert knows
that's not funny that's a little funny
was I supposed to come back here if I
wasn't supposed to come back here I'm
going to be very upset am I supposed to
be here hi what's up damn you and your
big barrel chest God damn you hey noses
you know used gun goes is you going goes
You're Gonna Fly one last fly up into
the sky
uh-huh you understand nose use gonna go
no look me in the eye look me in the eye
look at me no look at me nose nose look
at me you're gonna die you're gonna die
nose nose You're Gonna Go
nose come on what are you doing nose
you're not looking at me in the eye
you're looking at me in like my shoulder
what's up with that yeah whatever
okay not a thought in the head not a
thought in the head Nary a thought up in
that skull
noses
noses causes
nose is gone
what can you do
man
what can you do pulling a newness on us
a card on on nose look I don't know what
what what you think we had but we Unison
does not have a copyright on dying
um that that stuff goes around
uh so and especially around noses noses
noses and death is uh is a like a thing
I got a hat can I put that on my thing
not my dick
I'm at my
other thing my why can't I think of a
drone
throne
turn the volume what down up what do you
what do you want I don't I don't know
what you want up down what the music the
music is supposed to be quiet
music is ambiance
please tell me the audio
hat chef
match remote nice
where is it
hello
that's that's pretty cute that's that's
pretty cute all right so there must be
something else oh wait I remember I just
my brain finally processed that I looked
down this place
oh
what
hello
[Music]
is that you Batman when the queen
mentioned having many visitors in one
day I knew it had to be you
listen whatever happened to me whatever
I tried doing to you
just no it wasn't actually me
I was forced to obey without much
thought
I tried communicating with you from afar
for a reason
now you know the true reason why
still I want to make it up to you
the queen filled me in on the situation
with the elevator I want to help with
that
I feel much more in control now I'll
come help you find the missing pieces of
the elevator
I just need to rest for a little bit and
I'll meet you at whatever that station
is
okay uh I was not listening I was so not
listening um
you not gonna kill me and this is a
hospital with no doctors uh that's what
I learned someone's waiting for you in
the Cell at the end of the hall uh uh
huh
what well that's terrifying
the music is so loud is it
is it
is is it what what do I need
[Music]
I'll do I'll do anything to make the
volume right for you I will I will go
I'll go to the ends of the Earth for you
and your volume needs I would I will do
anything
for your volume
I'm on my knees begging
to tell me what your volume needs are I
will
I will make the volume so good for you
I think it's so good for you it's all
right okay it's good all right cool
I'm sure it is dear Mommy we just had
the best party ever
Miss Mason Miss Miss Mason okay all
right well this is definitely from
the kindergarten part of this
um
[Music]
hello
well we're gonna do we're gonna do a
trick okay we're gonna do our we're
gonna do our little trick here right we
just I just want to see what's going on
there there's
I just want to see if there's anything
to be seen
oh
foreign
I like being able to do that I like I
like being able to do that let me just
close that down a bit
there we go
okie dokie then all right
that's good to know
well
here I go
oh why
why
why you got why in those tubes
is that supposed to be like shackles
uh-huh
what do you think what is this
oh hi
oh
it's you yeah
don't worry
I'm unable to hurt you
I'm too weak to do anything
by not listening to me and leaving when
you have the chance you have made a
great mistake
finally after managing to keep Josh
under control
you just had to come around and anger
him Josh
look where you're arrogant Scholars now
a position where neither of us can get
to the children
this is your fault and nobody else's
I meant it when I said I would practice
the safest procedures
but regardless
I have something I want to show you
uh-huh it sure looks like you need it
huh
oh
what are you do oh oh
we crashed well is that my fault hi
you're up again I you sure are a sleepy
fellow uh-huh
agree
grab some of the vegetables fast we
collected indeed
huh oh they're all finished oh
I already have consumed my share of the
nutrients who have gathered while you
were in your slower
me too sorry about that
oh
all right well that's not very cool but
uh oh oh uh oh I don't think I want it
anymore
I don't I don't know if I want that ah I
have never witnessed kindness
man if gently Josh was here
I am pretty content that he's not greasy
because it is
uh-huh why do you hate him so much sure
he's got some anger issues but overall
he's pretty chill we've had our fair
share of altercations
haters one of the two emotions I am
unable to control what's the second one
oh
not again
how is any being able to fast constant
sorrow in a world like ours
sometimes I feel like we're always just
doing forever we each have our plans and
goals but at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter
nor can it undo the past or a previous
misery
life is too short to be sad all the time
stinger
Our Lives
well I don't know what to tell you
you know I'm not the best at this stuff
maybe NAB NAB or the captain can help
okay
the captain
Captain okay captain
as expected
is that the bird's name NAB NAB that's
Bam Bam backwards
what's that sound
that's probably fine lots of other
creatures reside in this ecosystem well
that was a train I don't know if well
it was a train it was very clearly a
train
[Music]
yeah but what kind of animal makes that
sound I'm less convinced it's a train
please
foreign
[Music]
are they allowed to do that
are you allowed to do
ah man
[Laughter]
I'm gonna operate on the assumption that
they did ask
uh and that's just like you know the
developers know each other or something
or I don't know they had permission okay
I was gonna assume that I was gonna
assume that that is
hilarious that's
that is uh I thoroughly enjoyed that I
think that that's something that um
I think that was pretty good I think
that was pretty good that was pretty uh
pretty good
I don't know why we were there I don't
know what kind of lesson we were trying
to learn oh hey hey handbag's gone
um but I feel good about myself I feel
good and I feel good about what I'm
doing here so I'm gonna go get another
elevator parting
oh boy I'm gonna keep rolling I'm Gonna
Keep training on I'm gonna keep trucking
um yeah if you didn't know yeah that was
apparently choo choo Charles that was
that was legitimately choo choo Charles
and I think I think that spider was um
these are either soothing The Savage
Beast or uh flirting with them I've been
waiting for a while oh you know the next
piece that we need should be at the
second station the feeding sector ah
okay all right I I'd almost forgotten
what I was supposed to be doing
um
nose oh you know there's another
there's another
there's another train okay all right
uh buy nose now is a good time to
introduce ourselves which we haven't
done up to this point if you can believe
it no
I'm listening
I worked here before everything came
crashing down
literally and figuratively
I can't imagine the stuff you've
witnessed down here you've seen most of
it my co-workers and I should have
spoken up sooner
perhaps all of this should have been
prevented then
but then again my co-workers weren't
really friends in those class couple of
months anyway so would have needed some
good playing
you ever had those friends that suddenly
turn on you for no reason
to say my intern on me would be an
understatement
they suddenly stopped talking to me they
looked at me like I was some sort of
monster
sometimes I lose my temper sure but it
seemed excessive
I was and still am confused to say the
least
we're here
let's get going where are what that that
way bud bro why are you looking at me
like that I don't know
I don't like any of this where are you
going what are you looking at uthman
othman
Earthman
Earthman this is his name is uthman I
thought I was bad at naming thing
uthman didn't know how bad your parents
were naming you
oh why can't
move
uh uthman
ufi
uh let's see
youth
[Music]
you'll see oh boy
I seem to be
yes
I think we gotta do one of those things
um
I think we gotta
now that being said I don't think I've
had a single crash in this game up until
this point where am I what is that
what are you doing wait get down
why
you know that these aren't solid you can
see right through
okay
[Music]
oh okay
that must have been a trap that the
sheriff set up earlier uh-huh poor Josh
I can't imagine how confusing this has
all been for I'm sure well I mean I've
also been incredibly confused but I'm
also confused as to what the hell you're
doing with that wasn't locked the last
time I was here wouldn't that have been
like ages ago it can be too hard to get
it open though right God you're just the
same as a sheriff never mind I I've
humbly apologized
oh I see it's one of these puzzles
oh never mind no it's not what
I've done it
genius is uh my calling in life I am
incredibly smart thank you oh look it's
noses parents
I always thought this looks oh
all right
we
um
oh you guys were spoiling
oh you guys were spoiling do you think
you're helping
hmm do you do you think look at this
what do you think
you're helping huh do you think you're
helping oh oh we'll just give do you
think I'm dumb how dumb do you think I'd
be how stupid do you think I am if I
can't figure out one puzzle that
requires walking around the corner ban
everybody just ban everybody
March
come on
are the mods here but Ben ever ever can
I ban everybody
we ban everybody is that possible
all right but you're on thin ice
oh there they are yeah band everybody
band everybody band everybody Band full
band across the board 100 band uh
uh bam
thank you ban ban that's why it's called
band actually
yeah all 43 872 of you yes please Ben um
that would be lovely if that occurred
immediately so get to Bannon anyway I'm
gonna play you guys get to hear me play
but you don't get to see that's your
punishment you guys want to spoil the
game for me I won't spoil the game for
you wow this game's so cool whoa what is
that actually what is that man that
would be crazy if you guys saw that oh
well whoa I see something cool I'm gonna
open this door now
wow look at that what are you oh
you guys can't see anything though
that's all your fault it's all your
fault you deserve this I just want you
to remember this
I want you to remember this 12 years
from now when you're just about to go to
sleep you're gonna wake up and you're
gonna think of this memory and you're
just gonna go oh God
just remember that
okay here you go
wow wasn't that cool see you would have
missed that
and well you would have heard that but I
don't know what that is oh
all right nothing is funny enough yep
this is hilarious though
really gotta admit hilarious okay
all right wait I'll test this out on you
okay
all right
how did the jellyfish get to the sea
floor
they took the jelly Vader
okay that's good what do you call a
surgery being performed on a kangaroo
okay
a operation
uh they're all terrible am I the joke
yep sure are
and not a very good one
oh
is this an elevator part are you looking
at me wow you just come in here steal
what's ours and then leave oh
you humans are all the same these with
no shame your greed Knows No Limits only
controllable for minutes
you can have the crown I couldn't care
less about that
but can I at least have some Applause
for my little poem please
goodbye
don't listen to that guy over there all
he cares about are his poems
I'll show you something that's actually
impressive
a magic trick
open sesame
[Music]
I think I earned a round of applause for
that
what was I think
uh uh I'll pause you in a second I could
have just hit and Locker in an isolated
room or something but you know what
paper I am content when I die here and I
have accepted that it's a matter of of
of when not if just like knows at least
my mind will be at ease I finally gotten
the answers to a question that had me
sleepless for weeks I finally know
what's down here and given that I will
probably never sleep again even if I
somehow miraculously make it out alive
after what I have witnessed I am content
whatever this establishment was hired to
find out about
I doubt they ever thought it would
involve their workers getting eaten by
giant clay animals clay
that's what they're made of
ah that makes sense close close
all right
okay
[Applause]
oh
no
nope
well I don't have enough to
suppose I could do that
but I don't know about that other one
get it get it get it get it get it get
it
[Music]
uh that one
God
I'm so fascinated that this mechanic is
still a part of this game because I know
this is in the very first one but I
don't know of anybody that looks at
their drone and just goes like Oh I'm so
fond of my drone I hope it doesn't die
oh man I really want my drone
hat
hat for my drone I did put a chef's hat
so I guess I am one of the people that
are like
I love my drone so I guess I'm I'm one
of them so whatever
whoops
huh get it
get it droney
damn you
pop damn it
okay we got this
up boom
did I get it
hmm
huh
oh
right of course that makes a lot of
sense
all right I got it I got I got it yeah I
got it see this isn't even one where
you're giving me spoilers this is just
like I got it it just takes me time but
even if I was doing this in a recorded
video I wouldn't cut it out because I'd
make you endure all of it because I just
want you to have the entire experience
of everything that I have to offer every
single second of video the content that
I put out is cherishable and gold which
also is why if you haven't been
listening to distractible and are
watching it
because it's video now and now you have
no excuse all you people that are like I
Need video to have duh this you just
hate podcasts which what is the
difference what is the difference you're
the problem not me did you know did you
even know that there is and even forego
if you're a sport person or not
I can't believe it can't believe it
can't believe it
why do I spend so much of my time
outraged at you
is that a me problem
no why do you spend so much of your time
making me outraged how dare you cause me
so much pain and suffering that is that
is unacceptable that is unacceptable
behavior from you to me to make me that
outraged
why don't you go watch some distractible
it's pretty good stuff
[Music]
um oh
ah what did I get oh floor four
oh for a red card four floor four gotcha
after stream yeah do that it's good
um
practice safety and you'll be okay all
right I'm gonna be okay now
you should be sorry nah you like
distractible you really would and it is
good to have video now also we're at two
videos a week I don't know if you knew
that we do two episodes a week now all
right we'll be okay I know
okay so it's I don't have to wait for
the other ones don't look at me God real
weirdo
[Music]
there are six feet two doors behind each
other I think we open the inner one oh
okay thanks for saying that out loud
before we grab the elevator piece
there's something I need to do first
what could you pause I need to hand this
imposter over to someone very close to
me
oh you do the honors what
what what
what what do you what do you mean oh
that's you
I don't know how I didn't see the
resemblance before oh of course
[Music]
must have gotten very lonely but I got
him a new friend
how
we wait what do you mean we wait why we
wait what do we wait wait no nap
[Music]
we can't let nap take him what what how
what what
no well I don't know no
oh God no why I don't know
please anything but whatever's happening
God God no I can't live no
oh God suffering
please why do good things happen to bad
people
oh no take me instead
oh god oh don't worry I'll take the
shortcut
I tried fixing you so many times if
you're just unfixable yeah
enough is enough
I was about to turn up my brightness
see this
all right
um
everything good in here I can control it
I know I can uh-huh yeah I have a few
things I need to do around here you'll
go back without me
the elevator part should be around here
somewhere
where are you
why is your voice coming out of nabnam
over here
um okay I got the elevator part I guess
uh
well it's been real boys
um
let's see around I guess ah here we go
as stated in the last update regarding
case nine the GV solution utilized to
altercase 13 Behavior has been applied
to case nine in order to eradicate the
Primitive behaviors observed previously
and the results are very promising
contrary to his behavior in the past
case nine it's not only just the
nocturnal sleeping cycle that was most
likely a direct result of a genome donor
and which is made testing very difficult
for the researchers he has now mastered
bipedal walking and seems to have
completely stopped mimicking the
movement of tahoots which mainly
consists of hopping The Next Step will
be to introduce case 9 to the concept of
speech which is speculated to take very
little time as a human genome Domer case
9 is a native English speaker case is
not ready for presentation
what
oh
can I have a break
can I get coffee
can I get one billion ban coins that
would be great
delightful
well I don't know why we went down here
and I don't know what he was trying to
do with the stick figure dude I I'm
gonna call it an endoskeleton but I know
that's not what it is because that's
Five Nights at Freddy's and that's not
this but I have no idea what I'm doing
and why I'm doing it here but I'm having
a great time I'm having I'm having a
great time what is supposed to be down
there
all right nothing I guess
to a whole lot of
whole lot of nothing over there just a
whole big thing of nothing
can't see a thing
let me turn up the brightness maybe I'll
see something
who knows I don't think this is gonna
work with probably nothing in the
darkness over here
oh definitely a whole lot of nothing
definitely nothing
definitely nothing that's still getting
closer definitely well there's nothing
nothing
whole lot of nothing guys can't believe
it
why wouldn't they put anything here
ah what can you do
time to move on
nah I don't see nothing I see nothing
guys I see a whole lot wow you know I
guess they just want to cut some Corners
in that section
whatever
goodbye everybody
just riding these alone now
yep
anyway so um how are you how are you
guys how are you doing how are you doing
you good you're good good to hear good
to hear good to hear uh I'm doing great
um I have to basically I'm
I'm
I'm sneaking out
right before the hurricane hits and I'm
gonna get out of here
um but not because I'm trying to escape
the hurricane but because I have work to
do if you didn't know editing up a storm
on iron lung uh progress is going well
um there's some cool things in
development that I can't tell you about
yet but that's not just because I'm
being ooh secretive trust me I want to
tell you everything about this movie I
want to tell you things that we did in
this movie that are Bonkers uh
like I've I've mentioned it before I
hinted at it before but I'm almost
positive
that we set the record for most blood
used in a horror movie I'm almost
positive
um so that would be dope uh
uh gotta keep things under the wraps for
a little bit
so should be very very very very cool
very cool
what was I doing
part
uh
right
when does the trailer come out so
there's still the issue with the strike
so there's the SAG strike and then
there's the rider strike so uh part of
it is like I am a member of sag which is
the screen actor's guild and the
production is like a very official
production and I'm trying to do things
by the book and so I cannot promote
anything
uh I mean I'm talking about it so I
guess that doesn't count as promotion
that's just me talking about my life
they're probably not paying attention to
this anyway but it doesn't matter
because I think you can just like talk
about things I'm not promoting it but
it's like I don't want to do anything
you know untowards that's two or three
great work partner thanks bud
so am I supposed to bring noses his nose
I can't even get nose all right nose you
just don't want to die I got spooked
yep yeah it'd be pretty good
yeah it'd be pretty good
yeah
keep talking I mean I can keep talking
but there's nothing to talk about just
yet I I do want to get back into videos
I had to go through an editing Sprint
um because I'm editing the movie because
I needed to get things done uh up to a
certain level
um it's the same thing I was doing with
like space and stuff except but I wasn't
editing that one um this one's I'm
editing because it's a movie it just
needs more personal touch and it whereas
like with space it's like shooting it
basically is the edit I mean not the
editors worked on it didn't do it like
nothing but it's like it's it's all it's
a series of Runners basically
um but this being something else I just
got to put my craft into it so it takes
time I gotta go look at it
I hope your journey was worth it yes
still doesn't work
we're very close to having it fully
fixed we we
children
we
when you do find them can I ask for a
favor ah Maybe
could you try and occasionally come
visit
it's been so long since we've had a
visitor that isn't trying to harm us
please do
other than that I don't want
it any longer well that's very sweet of
you I won't but it's a very sweet
friends have arrived if you'd like to go
check on them
my friends my my friends my friends what
do you mean my friend I don't have any
friends here I don't have friends
I don't have any friends
now nothing nothing about release yet I
I can't say anything about that through
the agreements the strike is still
ongoing
still ongoing
well we talked about it quite a bit if
you haven't been watching on
distractible and even go we've been
talking about it so that's where I've
kind of been keeping up with things even
though I haven't been doing videos which
is something that I do want to get back
to I've been sitting on some things like
I I do this where I'm like well I don't
want to I don't want to post videos
unless I'm able to come back but after I
get back from this trip I'll be back but
I've been sitting on like
three scary games 100 I've been sitting
back on um
this animation for distractible I've
been sitting on a ton of things so I
just wanted to get this because I was
losing my mind not being able to do
anything was that it
is that it yeah I want to do more sons
of the forest just don't have time to
record anything God we only just got
started into that
oh there's so many things I want to do
thankfully I was able to play ruin when
I was when it came out that was very
convenient because I was I was still
editing like when that was coming out
but it was great to be able to just do
something but then I got so busy that I
was just like there's only so much work
you can do in a day like I I like I I
I'm kind of crazy about work I work
pretty much all the time but there's
there literally is only so this is the
first entry to what I will refer to as
the toadster archives
where all information gathered about
criminals will be recorded
criminal number one the snail was
captured near the front Gates of the
Kingdom while I was on patrol I don't
care this deal was captured while hiding
in her cell has remained hidden since I
don't wanna it was initially thought to
be an empty shell until quiet crying
with her coming from within the cell
all attempts to convince the snail to
leave her shell have failed
the reason for this extreme distress is
not yet but determined
but I have a theory
this criminal ain't from around here
so it's possible that this foreign
hostile environment is what's causing
this unnatural Behavior
more updates soon yeah okay uh too long
didn't listen uh snail said could have
said that in two words though
Hey your baby's alive
this is the third entry to the toadstock
oh
criminals numbers three and four the
birds were captured by being lured in
their current holding cells
their sudden and unannounced appearance
within the walls of the Kingdom took me
by surprise but they are now safely
contained
they seem to be very territorial as they
did not exhibit any hostile Behavior as
long as they kept my distance from their
cell
it also seems that they were frantically
looking for something
although I'm not sure what exactly
since containment they've remained
completely still I think they might be
trying to trick me into getting into
check on them
I'm not falling for that
more updates soon well nose is over
there but I a man parents I'm so sorry
in the future nose is gonna goes I oh
man Mr and Mr noses I wow
well that can't be comfortable
[Music]
all right whatever
this is the second entry to the
toadstock
criminal number two the teacher was
captured near the elevator that goes
down from the third floor where a human
was also captured earlier
unlock the snail the teacher was
extremely hostile towards me starting a
missing student from her class as the
reason she's even down here
numerous failed attempts to escape were
recorded but it appears she's finally
given up
numerous objects were introduced in an
attempt to calm her down with only a few
excess bowling pins seemed to do the job
the teacher has been sitting in a corner
since comment down repeat in the
sentence I can't be late to herself over
and over
truly an interesting case
[Music]
clear for attention to detail
um
she is not sitting in a corner I just
really really really have to point that
out it's um
she's not sitting in a corner she is
sitting
um literally in the opposite of the
corner
this is the fourth entry to the toaster
archives
criminal number five the Green Gorilla
was captured by Fallen victims to an
intricate trap that was designed and set
up in the feeding sector by yours truly
so far the Green Gorilla has been
chained so not too much information has
been retrieved
so far today we've received seven cases
in only a few hours
it's very unnatural
something up above has happened that's
causing these cases to end up down here
it hurts the unfamiliar faces in this
state
but I cannot risk my health to help old
friends that may have gone mad
more updates soon all right
um okie dokie then uh was I supposed to
do something about that or was any of
this supposed to be usable for me or
was I just supposed to take all that in
his knowledge in my skull and then move
on um
and also am I do do I go do now to the
third piece or do I come back and do
something else for what's in the
Darkness
that's what I want to know what's in the
I gotta know what's in the dark nothing
nothing in the darkness there's there
ain't nothing in the darkness okay the
darkness ain't ain't nothing
but now do I go
I go over
there
my
goal exercise
oh
ah okay I go exercise alone I'm I'm
thinking am I am I forgetting things
probably
I give nose back I don't think so I give
noses ashes back when I cremate those
that's what nose once nose nose nose
knows with nose wants yes it's very good
it's good yes
I know I know I haven't finished Shadows
there's another ending in FNAF ruin
praise be I can't wait to get it how do
I get it tell me tell me how I get a new
ending in FNAF ruin
tell me I want to know I want to know so
badly
how do I do it how how do I do it
Mark how is ADHD affected my life
let me tell you
let me tell you the ways let me explain
to you the ways I haven't exactly been
able to get a new prescription in a
little bit which has made things very
difficult part of the reason why I
haven't been able to
um concentrate on multiple things is
like my days are so frazzled lately
um it's not even that there's a shortage
uh because there is a shortage but the
prescription that I have called the
Stars there's actually not a shortage of
um so I it's just like it's been a
mixture of things where I'm like I'm so
busy number one that I haven't been able
to get a new doctor because I I
mentioned when I'm playing nephron my
doctor just stopped answering the phone
um and then two getting a doctor or a
psychiatrist is difficult and then stuff
like that uh so right now it's a little
it's a little strained I'm not gonna lie
um so
hey
thirties
yeah I take Space Marines will really
cure your ADHD that's that's what it is
I know it's called astorus
um and uh it's my preferred one but I
can't get anything right now because
oh then I probably schedule it like I
don't know if it's an ADHD thing to not
be able to schedule an appointment or
follow up on things but I can't do that
right now and I can't even brain
properly most of the days and I
definitely can't multitask on on days I
I can barely get through the stuff that
I need to do
um so it's been a little difficult but
not not for any other fault but my own
and I guess my old doctor
but that's something else it's it's
something that like with with daily
habits I'm able to manage because
there's many things that you can do for
ADHD without medication it's it's
definitely not like the ultimate uh end
goal that all people should go for but
for for me in particular uh it is
let
no it's not even a pharmacy thing now
well it was a pharmacy thing because the
pharmacy that I went to they're a bunch
of and I'm not lying about that
I actually like know for a fact that the
farm why Turtle it
is it just to say I'm in the bathroom
because I know
I know I'm in the bathroom
a minute
okay all right what the is
Scooby-Doo toilet
I don't want to know you know what don't
tell me I'd like to live in ignorance
just I I this is one of those things
that I just want to be I'm too old for
this I'm just going to say that straight
up I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna do
anything about that yeah no it's but
it's not it's not it's not a fault but
like my own and like I haven't been able
to follow up and there's too many things
that I have to do and so things start
falling through the cracks that that is
like inevitable and that's what I feel
bad about is like especially with say
for example making videos and being able
to edit on the same days like it just
gets a little too much it gets a little
too much
I've not gonna look up skippity totally
case 14 was moved to her new dwelling
this morning to which she expressed
satisfaction but natural nervousness as
perk Management's request further
research on the phenomenon of case 14's
pouch
damn case 14
sprawl was conducted
and found to be fat on while the
research is provided invaluable
observations very little in terms of
explanation can be confirmed it appears
that any and all givenium-grown bodies
experience a lot of difficulty leaving
the pouch once inside
so you got that right anyway especially
more so if Case 14 chooses to hold the
pouch shut
all right okay I was joking around this
is this is weird reflexes appears to
loose in case 14's ability to hold the
pouch shut at will
see my eyes are burning my everything is
burning I I don't like what I'm reading
the reason for any case is inability to
leave the pouch has been theorized to be
the result of some sort of attraction
don't Mark me don't Mark me that's not
my fault
look you're reading this I'm not making
this up
it just stays
the traction between
GV particles when they're within very
close proximity such as a body being
within the interior of a pouch
pouch cases permanently not ready for
presentation
don't Mark me this you see this it's not
me
not me
oh God I don't know whatever I'm I'm
no no no no no no
and don't worry I'll follow up it's just
like I gotta go I gotta fly tomorrow and
then I gotta come back and then I got a
whole bunch of other things and it's
just like it's a big deal it's a big
it's a big hoo-ha for a lot of things
that I'll get it taken care of
um I won't have a problem getting this
prescription like it's been since the
long time ago if you've been following
like there was there was probably
because of stars with new now it's been
around a while I didn't get it it's just
like I just it's so hard with ADHD
medication sometimes but it's
I've uh man if I can just
what am I even doing I don't even know
anymore ah no change what is going on
hmm three games two rounds each lights
out something in one of the rooms might
have changed report the room where they
are you kidding me you're gonna make me
play observation Duty
oh no
[Laughter]
[Music]
no
I know it Spot the Difference is not
just the observation duty but whatever
all right okay so I gotta memorize oh
God I got America three chairs four
apples
so many boxes oh man
oh man I'll do the thing I did in
observation Duty you just gotta sweep
your head across ah it's a sweep to
sweep sweep sweep sweeping sweeping
sweep sweep I'm sweeping I'm sweeping
just keep your head moving don't worry
about your eyes your eyes will follow
where the eyes go don't worry it's I got
it okay I'm ready how do I start this
two pales got it
got it you yes
oh
or something might have changed okay
four apples two pails okay this looks
fine okay boxes that box looks yeah it's
fine uh uh all silverware is there okey
dokey uh keep moving swing head that
actually is the same okay nothing's
changed not a damn thing and you can't
prove otherwise nothings have changed
what no no you lie no no no no no no the
boxes are the same they're all the same
it's all the same
no change
what what
oh I'm not dead I thought I was dead
okay all right okay I got this don't
worry guys I got this don't worry
I wonder if I turn up the gamma when it
goes out
oh
ah
well that's a little obvious
it's pretty obvious
[Music]
the boxing the Box
[Laughter]
listen if you make a Brian Regan uh
reference I'm gonna laugh every time
the flock of boxing mood the boxing was
that always there
toilet paper over or under
I don't know chair chair what chair no
Chad
cool good good all right let's do good
uh what room is that uh this
definitely
that's that room
nice nice nice nice
well I did it
oh my god do they want oh my oh my God
oh my God
oh God oh God
three games two rounds I have to do this
six times oh
all right here we go oh well that was
easy
don't worry guys I got this
the chairing
the chores
don't tell me the suffer you're in here
with me we do this together
whoop
boxes are not fine
[Music]
thank you that's actually easier than I
thought it'd be I thought I'd have to
like count all the all the random
nonsense
all right
um
well it's Gotta Be boxes every time
apparently the boxing gosh the boxing
ah
talk to the oh well sun room
yes a new record
[Music]
I did it
morning exercise checklist cognitive
physical communicative ah
okay oh
uh
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
it's a puppy
puppy
it's not a puppy
Christmas
our
I'm not sure what I was supposed to do
there I don't really know
okay I was about to say if I had to do
that again I was going to be extremely
upset come here you come here I'm gonna
tickle your bum come here ah damn
all right fine whatever you say
um so what am I supposed
to be white
okay so so
well
oh
thank you
well that's weirdly easy
oh
[Music]
thank you
I'm dead I was trying to read I saw a
sign in there
so um
so no no don't tell me don't tell me I
got this so what I need to do so I got
this i got this okay so what I need to
do what I need to do
is
I need two
get you I'm coming to get you a little
thing you can run from me what I need to
do
is I gotta hit the buttons quicker right
so I need to hit all four that's what
I've been taught in this game thus far
so I just need to hit the button better
and that way I'll be able to get them
all so I just got to be really fast
right
so I'm going to charge this one up to
like build up the timer on it yeah you
feeling me you get me right
so I'm gonna build up the timer on it
and then I'm gonna I'm gonna really get
them all don't you worry don't worry I
got it all right here we go see see I
see red I go get red that's what I see
red means dead so don't worry I'm gonna
get this
watch this watch this all right
all right he's just coming for me I
don't know about that one
hmm interesting
all right don't worry guys nah I got
this oh Jesus
that didn't make any sense at all
why did that occur
excuse me
[Music]
do it
ah
thank you
man it runs stupidly anyway so um
okay
I'm doing it wrong no no no no no no no
no
no no don't worry I got this guys
don't worry I got this I got this don't
worry
don't worry I got this don't worry I got
it die guys
I got this don't worry I got this
all right
I think I'm starting to get it I think
I'm starting to get something
I've got a little bit of
some Moon
it's not moving in my head I think I got
this
I got this i got this let me read in
here
meow like friends who are the face of it
I was closer than I thought it was
all right don't worry wow hey what's up
what are you doing stop stop
okay you come this way and then I'm
gonna I'm gonna bet it all I'm betting
it all You're Gonna Roar and you're
gonna you're gonna charge yeah I do it I
do
[Applause]
it
[Music]
is it dead
yeah I did it all right it's dead good
riddance hated that thing from the
moment I saw it terrible thing hey I'm
starting to like the system of
communication it's hard to do what we
wanted without speaking to each other in
private for a suspicious amount you know
how they handle suspicions suspicious in
this place what I don't like is
happening is to sometimes leave our
messages at this floor as much as I
understand that it is necessary
sometimes I just can't help but feel
watched down here anyway I've collected
the data of all the children currently
enrolled in the kindergarten and left
them at your desk I've marked my
preferred genome donors
and you do your same
we can then exclude any students that
aren't marked by the both of us and then
form the smaller pool of candidates we
pick one to proceed with well that's
weird I don't know anything about that
hey what's with these reactions or like
I know that this is a thing in a lot of
other uh
and a lot of other streaming things
I'm not 100 sure why it was necessary
here
give me
some give something give me some give me
give me a give me this expression
give me a lot of that
give me that I want to see that is that
something you could do there it is oh
that's great that's good stuff hey
that's great is that supposed to make
you feel better is this supposed to
encourage me as a streamer to keep going
just like seeing just beady eyes staring
at me floating upwards from chat
because that's a lot of what I'm getting
I don't know what I'm getting
anyway I feel very encouraged I feel I
feel unraptured actually I feel I feel
like I'm I'm really killing it in this
streaming gig maybe I'll be a big stream
or something oh man probably not though
not quite ready for work go through here
yeah
[Music]
Frick is it
oh okay I'm gonna charge up my crystals
apparently
okay
I don't know why I'm charging up my
crystals
um
but I am
Queen bounce Ellie is looking for
crystals for her crown okay I see what
it is all right didn't I got a crown a
while ago
was I supposed to give that to the queen
I probably was anybody seen another one
around here there's one more Crystal
that I'm missing
one more Crystal
keep your eyes peeled keep those peepers
big and wide give me the eyes give me
the eyes everybody lend me your eyes let
me your eyes you don't give me your eyes
right now I'm never gonna find this
you're gonna give me your peepers give
me all your peepers
trying to keep all the peepers for
yourself
people's peepers peeled
where the cricket what the frick is it
you're not giving me your peepers
you're not you you're not you're not
giving me your peepers I can't see it do
you see it does anybody see it nobody
sees it where is it where's the people
there's no we're not enough peepers
where is it
guys I swear to God if you guys are
holding off you're holding back behind
the chair I look behind the chair
there's another oh
huh
what what
cheater
cheater cheater
cheater cheater cheat cheated I cheated
can't believe
oh man where's these Elevator Parts why
were they put everywhere
why
you asked no no no no you that was a
trick that was a test that was a test
man how hard can I gasoline you guys how
hard can I guess
ah man I'm trying my damnedest you're
just you're ungaslightable you're on
gaslightable you just can't be
like a month
I won't lie I thought the dinosaur would
finish you off but if it's driving you
will get you out of my way too then who
am I to complain
I tell you a very fitting joke like you
humans just never seem to get them
the closest people to me denied me what
I was made to do people who were
genetically programmed to laugh at my
damn joke
they cited some end of the world
scenario where whatever's in the Queens
pouch escapes if I make her laugh but
I'm not buying it
I was distraught and I became dead set
on making the ultimate joke
but after failing time and time again I
realized something
I am the ultimate jokester
there was nobody better to be made even
if by me
with the sheriff occupied
reaching the queen will be a piece of
cake
I will go now because unlike you my path
to having my family back has never been
clearer
oh man you walked them
um so why uh why um why didn't you just
go to the queen before I I was literally
out here all alone in the time it took
you to declare your evil plan I feel
like you could have just I don't know
made the queen laugh maybe you're just
not funny
maybe you're just not funny you know I'm
just saying it like ah maybe not you
know what I mean probably not
anyway how are you guys are you good
good this game is longer than I thought
it would be
this game is a bit longer than I thought
I thought it'd be you know quick in-out
hour hour tops I've been blasting
through it too right I've been blast
it's a good idea
content in it
for sure
bears oh man I don't want it to end
the guy sounded like me how dare you
huge what the
damn what
why did you do that
why would you just say that why would
you say that why would you say that guy
sounds like me why would you say that
oh I can't believe that
you archiving this that is such a
strange way to say that this will be
posted on my channel afterwards but yes
I guess I'll archive this I think
huh you know I don't know why but you
know for those of you who listen on
distractible I've been talking very much
about
why is the queen up high I don't know
what's going on I've been talking very
much about like my pet peeves and things
that I've been dealing with you're lucky
I don't inundate you with those troubles
you're lucky I don't blast my opinions
about like
storage uh like hard drives and various
um developments in the worlds of ndmes
SDS and like the new 61 terabyte nvma
SSD that's coming out that I'm
salivating over because I'm like oh my
God I'll be able to put the whole movie
on just two of those drives because it's
90 terabytes a day you're lucky you're
lucky I don't blast that out all over
you you're you're lucky that I don't
give my uh on unrequested Mac opinions
now because I'm I'm I'm just oh
according to everybody I'm a just an
apple Fanboy huh because I like editing
on a Mac now oh that's my fault it's my
fault I can't believe you
what am I guessing I don't even know
anymore guys it has been a while since I
was able to get
a prescription
um
so I'm I'm working on that I'm working
on that I promise I'm working on that
promise I'm working on that
I can't I just for some reason it
doesn't matter how much I plan I well
actually I don't plan at all so I can't
plan
ADHD is strong with this one I swear
it would be better
it would be better it would be a lot
better but uh no fault but my own
ADHD meds are so easy to get I don't
know who you are
who are you what no I don't know where
you live no
um well yes
but no
yes but also no ah man
I just I know it's that's a thing it's
like some things are like
should be so easy you know like a clear
path you don't understand how hard it
was to even like when I first got
diagnosed when I was like 21 to even
like go four
uh getting a diagnosis that was that was
really tough shouldn't I be afraid or
something I guess not
hello
your majesty
I have finally come to do what I was
made for and deliver my jokes this is my
best
okay
I feel like I should stop this or
something oh
foreign
[Applause]
all I wanted to make you laugh
nose grows yes nose
I do and I told myself time and time
again that some things are more
important than laughter
but I can't wait anymore
I need to make you laugh even if just
for a little bit
I can't even put aside again
I am nothing without a rule or salinity
I am sorry
your majesty tell me
what did the train conductor say to the
kangaroo
oh boy
what's terrible
what the heck
oh oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
hold on wait everyone needs to stop I
oh
number one so many things happened just
now nose grows nose explodes there's so
much gold happening cause nose knows
that nose grows with nose dives into the
toes of the nose
and then freaking freaking Crotch Cannon
beam
what what is happening
huh anyway that was amazing I love this
game so much the naughty one
[Music]
God just opening this scene to the
naughty ones are escaping oh no not the
naughty ones oh my God I love this game
I unironically enjoy my time playing
this sometimes it's a drag sometimes
it's arduous sometimes it's a pain oh
hi
hello
other times worked so hard to build
there's gems of Beauty in here
but grab this one
will definitely be useful
we make it down there a lot we need to
find the Queen's scepter
it's the only thing that can stop this
madness
and there you have it
apparently and I I just have to point
out like
some things in this game are incredibly
fun and really make me laugh and I think
it's intentional it's not just I'm
laughing at stupidity here there's
there's things that I think the
developer knows are funny and I I like
it
each one of these is getting better than
the last in terms of like crafting it
right we're still a little rudimentary
but also
there's just such a like a such a
fantastic fascinating
inattention to detail that's how I have
to explain it there's such an
inattention to detail and nothing
explains it more than this screen right
here
because we just played Garden of ban ban
4.
this says Garden of ban ban sucks
and I was just like God it's so clear
and all of this like this there's this
there is both so much effort put into it
and also so little
is just
it's great
it's great I love it I love it I love it
unironically I'll defend the garden of
ban ban I defend Garden of ban ban I
defend it I defend it
I defend it
man
that was fun that was fun anyway uh so
wrapping up I forgot lexian was here hey
what's up bud
man uh anyway
just
curtain of ulthan of uthi uthman uthman
uthman Garden of uthman yes that's it
Garden movement anyway God I can't
listen to the music anymore
and give me a headache
um so yeah I'm I'm doing my best uh I'm
editing up a storm I'm getting things
done I want to get back into videos uh
very very soon it is inexcusable for me
to just like
let things slip like this and I know
it's just like it's my own fault because
I get busy and then I'm like oh I gotta
schedule this thing but it's like it's
also been extremely busy and I've been
trying and I will and I'm not I'm not
like apologizing for my ADHD that's not
what I'm apologizing for I'm getting
things done that are important and some
things do take priority like editing
this movie does take priority but
there's no reason in my mind anyway that
I can't also like make videos at the
same time and it's not even like I want
to like I make videos because I'm
obligated to it's like nah man I like
doing this that's what some like a
lot of other YouTubers don't seem to get
it for some reason and I don't
understand this I like making content I
like it I really do the reason I want to
make a movie is because I really like uh
making stuff I like making big things I
like playing silly games I like doing
these streams I like making content I
don't get why that's not more clear in
other YouTubers and other content
creators I do this because I like it but
also just like yeah I need to take more
time to um
get things in order and do that I love I
love doing this
I really do um so I'm gonna keep doing
that uh but hopefully I can do it with
uh some
like getting my prescription in order
which would be very nice uh I would like
that I would like that I like that a lot
so I'll get that order uh that settled
up so if there's any other
um questions concerns that you guys have
let me know uh I will
hopefully be back from this trip
Wednesday
and then I will be able to
take care of all of that
it's good
all good
no it's not that I need a br well okay I
need a break number one but I need a
break from the constant editing because
basically all I've done for the past
like three weeks is just I wake up and I
edit which is fine I don't mind doing
that
to some extent
um because I I like editing and I'm good
at editing because it's part of the the
creation of things and that's nice uh
but at the same time man and there's
some things in my life that I got to get
in order which I will do that also so I
will do that thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank you for being
here and thank you for waiting patiently
I do have some more content there's
three scary games 100 coming out soon
very special or not I don't know
depending on if you like it or not but
you better
um and then uh an animation please
listen to distractible that has still
been coming out every week please listen
to go my favorite sports team that's the
podcast with Tyler about sports or not
Sports stuffer not sport people because
I'm not a sports person but you will
love it even if you're not a sports
person and then distractible has video
now on Spotify so go check it out if you
don't know where to watch on Spotify you
gotta get the app if you were if you're
well I mean how else do you get it
besides the app I guess you go to the
website
anyway go check out distractible we have
videos now it's very funny
most of the time
which is like how it is for all my
videos so thank you and as always
I'll see you in the next one
bye-bye